I have colon cancer with metastasis to my lungs recently have had lyridio spasm twice which is very scary
Is there a thing I could do at home to help with this? Thank you for advice
So lyridio spasm
can be from
multiple different
Causes to that so but what a person says they have metastasis to the lungs
Then it's always a concern that is there uh is there
The the cancer that's in the lungs. Where is it? Is it putting pressure on a nerve? That's causing the
lyridio spasm is it a space-occupied lesion that's pressing on the
Airflow I don't know for sure
So we'd really need more data to help with this
Dealing with metastasis to the lungs, you know, you think about one of the things you could do to help with the
metastasis in the lungs you think of
Hydroproxide
Nebulized make sure you follow the dr. Mercola Nebulized
Recipe for hydroproxyl you don't nebulize straight hydroproxide you have to water it out
You think of corniceps is a good supplement as far as lung inflammation and lung healing the lungs
anything that's going to decrease
Inflammation will also be a benefit to this person corniceps is is a
Minisil mushroom that is also an adaptogen, but it's really good for the lungs
Those are the things I would think of and you'd want to get more data though is the
Is it the the space occupied this
quality of the lesion in the lung?
The issue is it the location of that lesion in the lung that's putting pressure on a nerve is it pressure on the
airflow
bronchial
Passages you don't want to get a little bit more data
To find out what the cause of that is